[Music]
we're joined now by Adam Seligman
vice-president of developer relations
now I love the theme of last night's
keynote get to the fun part
can you talk a little bit about how you
chose that theme and why you feel it
resonates without developers and really
all technical practitioners yeah you bet
thanks for having me it's exciting the
exciting to be here you know it was
super fun and the whole idea was to
really celebrate what developers and
operators actually do every day you know
hopefully they're spending hours a day
productively building apps running apps
- playing apps monitoring apps and not
dealing with all the other stuff you
know that you normally have to do when
you build applications especially in the
enterprise you know you know getting out
of waterfall and getting to agile not
just throwing over an app over the wall
for someone else to operate but taking
ownership and a DevOps culture and
operating and really removing all the
barriers everything from you know not
having to manage and shard databases not
have to manually like manage your VMs or
even pick VM sizes and really just you
know get to the heart of building
applications and then let the cloud take
care of it from there that that was the
spirit we wanted to capture in the
keynote
so configuring networks rewriting apps
due to cloud provider changes and
waiting around for build test and deploy
are clearly not the fun parts didn't
Google once face these sort of issues
and how were we able to remedy that at
such scale Google has put a lot of great
software to run these services that
billions of people use every day so a
lot of a couple of decades of experience
when it's how do we help Google
developers become incredibly productive
so they can spend an hour six hours on
average of writing software every day
and absolutely minimize everything else
in the chain of getting to deployment
and getting that service out to
production where a small number of users
can test it as a canary deployment and
start giving you feedback so we're
trying to build that into our cloud
we've seen the rise of DevOps practices
up out in the industry but now we're
building into our products with products
like cloud code like managed kubernetes
and CSP
cloud run our new server lists offering
just really reducing the barriers to
anyone like a Google engineer can build
code and get it in production as easily
as possible
fantastic now if you had to pick just
one just one best practice from
yesterday's keynote that you want
developers to walk away with what would
it be I'm gonna cheat a little and
instead of like I think Google said I
really like what twinkle desai said who
is a VP at Kohl's who started her career
as a developer and a UNIX is admin and
she built a lot of automation at calls
now she runs couple years later she runs
a 200-person team they have a hundred
micro services five thousand containers
it's all automated it's running on
manage gke on Prem she said they've been
through two big holiday shopping windows
which you know in retail is a really big
deal so I'm thrilled that Google cloud
can support retail customers but by
making her people super productive it's
been really great for calls and really
great for her career that's an
inspirational customer story we also saw
incredible demos during the keynote
yesterday can you tell us about some of
them and which one was your favorite ah
there was a couple that were a lot of
fun I really like what Wix is doing with
Google cloud you know they've gone from
being like a drag and drop web
environment but now it's totally totally
programmable and extensible at Google
Cloud that's really exciting the opening
demo that that Mandy Waite led us
through like her dev team is taking us
through was very very cool because it
was a mix of developers doing VM based
development with Jenkins for deployment
of new VM images a container based app
in the middle and then extending with
new services with functions serverless
functions which is pretty cool so to see
all those teams kind of working together
and using tools like cloud code our new
IDE integration for vs code and IntelliJ
just awesome people can work the way
they want to work it all works together
all runs at Google cloud seamlessly one
pane of glass with stack driver to
observe and manage it and I think that's
great let developers do what they want
and get to the fun parts that's
fantastic thank you so much again for
joining us today and giving us some of
that great information
[Music]